Music
Music Music Dune Dune Dune Dune Dune Dune Dune Dune Dune
Dune Dune Dune Dune Dune Dune Dune Dune Dune Dune Dune Dune
Dune Dune Dune Dune Dune Dune Dane D
🎵 🎵 🎵
🎵 🎵 It was so hard to see the two of us.
It was forever.
But that summer, you, and that love, and that love is
nowhere me nothing I I love
I love I love I love I love that summer love love CUNY CUNY
CUNY CUNY CUNY I'mれた CUNY CUNY Queun Call Call I'm CUNY i'm
CUNY CUNY CUNY DENY The love is endless Love is love But the
summer of the key is Showing you in a way Love is always the
way you love you I want to be able to be able to be That's
why I want to be able to be that feeling When we're
together, pet-tot-tot-tot-tot
Toc-toc-toc-tot-tot-toc-toc-toc-toc- That's why that moment
That the moment that's going to be That's why it's always
endless And I'm going to go I'm an envious It's a kynes,
it's a kynes I'm going to repeat it It's a kynes, it's a
kynes It's a kynesie It's an Olympiad Kynes, Kynes That
love, that's why I'm always
Overkeeping it's Kynes, Kynes, Kynes Kynes, Kynesine, it's
Kynes, Kynes, Kynes, Kynes, Kynes Ulames, it's an
Olympiades, it's Kynes, Kynes Yundes, yundes, yundes,
yundes, yundes, yundes, yundes, yundes, yundes, yundes,
yundes, yundes, you